[موسيقى]
من الخبرات والتجارب في المجالات الامنيه
وتدريب رجال الامن واتفق البلدان وقتها
ايضا على البدء بتفعيل الاتفاقيه الامنيه
وتنفيذ العمل بها من دون تاخير فور
استكمال اجراءاتها القانونيه بالتصديق
عليها من المؤسسات الدستوريه في البلدين
واعتبر وزير الداخليه الايراني انذاك عبد
الواحد موساوي الاتفاقيه الامنيه تطورا
مهما ونقله نوعيه وجيده في مجالات التعاون
بين السعوديه وايران مشيرا الى انه سيكون
لها اثر ايجابي على المنطقه كما قال حينها
الا ان التوتر عدم جديد بين البلدين في
عام
2005 مع خروج مهاشه ميرا سنجاني من منصب
الرئاسه ودخول منافسه المحافظ احمد نجاه
محله
ننظر بتفاعل الى المستقبل ونعمل على توطيد
العلاقه وخدمه المصالح جميع دول المنطقه
وحمايه امن المنطقه وهذا ما نط وحيده ان
شاء الله
اعود من جديد الى ضيوفي معالي السفير فهمي
عاده لما نتابع مثل هكذا محاولات لانشاء
اتفاقيات او لمحاوله
طرح مسار لتقارب دولتين نتابع التاريخ
وتاريخ الدولتان حافل بالمسائل الشائكه
بحسب خبره حضرتك هل كل ما حصل بين
الدولتين عبر سنوات عديده وكل الاخفاقات
السابقه التي عاشها هل هذا يرفع سقف
التوقعات يعني يخلي دولتين ياخذوا دروس
فبالتالي النقاط اللي تكون مطروحه تكون
اكثر دقه او ان هذا بالعكس هذا
يخفض من سقف التوقعات يخفض من سقف الثقه
خاصه بين الاطراف
يعني كلهم صحيح تاريخ العلاقات بين
الدولتين يعكس توتر ويعكس عدم تنفيذ
الالتزامات كثيره في اتفاقيات الجدوى في
الاتفاق ليس في نصوصه بقدر ما هو في وجود
الاراده السياسيه لتنفيذه التجربه في
العوامل الماضيه اعتقد اثبتت ويجب ان
نستخلص منها انه يجب يكون هناك اراده
سياسيه للتحاور وهذا شاهدناه يجب هنا جديه
في التحاور وهذا انعكس على استمرار الحوار
الايراني السعودي عامين قبل التوصل الى
هذا الاعلام وانما وسبب
هذا الاعلان بسبب هذا الاعلان يجب ان نرحب
به ونعمل على دعمه انما لا نبالغ بانه
الاعلان وحده
يحل كافه المشاكل واكرر ما ذكرته منذ
لحظات
الاعلان ايجابي جدا مصلحه لجميع الاطراف
الاقليميه عدا طرف واحد انما نجاحه او
فشله مرتبط بالافعال وليس فقط الاقوال
الخبره العمليه تجعلنا نهتم بالتفاصيل قبل
التوقيع وهذا ما تم
نهتم بما قيل وما لم يقال خلال المفاوضات
وخلال التفاوض لانه يعكس تردد الطرف الاخر
او اهتماماته
ونهتم ايضا بالمراجعه المستمره
التاكد التحقق من الالتزامات وتدرج في
التفاعل ولكن الوزير تحدثت حضرتك عما لم
يقل هل تعتقد بان ما لم يقل قد يكون اكثر
اهميه مما قيل بمعنى انه نحن نتحدث عن
سنتين من المفاوضات سنتين افضيا الى
اتفاقيات ما رشح منها فعليا هو
التطبيع الدبلوماسي العوده للعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه انصح التعبير ولكن هل تعتقد
بحسب خبرات حضرتك بانه هناك امور تم فعلا
البدء بترتيبها على المستوى العملي ولكن
لم تعلن بعد
اعتقد ان ما اعلن وكان مهما للغايه ليس
فقط استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه وانما
كذلك
التركيز الخاص على استئناف الاتفاق الامني
الانفاق الامني هو اللي ارتبط وهو اللي
اثار الكثير من التحفظات التي كانت موجوده
ثم في اشاره صريحه
تم ابرازها ايضا عدم التدخل في شؤون
الداخليه للدول فانا ارى في هذا اتفاق
ايجابي وانما ارض ارى ايضا انه قرار
استراتيجي من اطراف المعنيه قررت فيه سليم
بان علينا تحاور مع الجار بغيت محاوله
الوصول الى حلول انما لا يعني من يفكر
استراتيجيه بدل معنا لا يعني اطلاقا انه
ميني سذاجه او من التسرع انه لا يعلم انه
ما هو قادم اصعب
ويجب اتناول كافه قضايا العمليه ستطول
انما الخطوه ايجابيه وسليمه وارحب بها
الهاشميا من بين كل هذه الملفات التي كنا
نتحدث عنها
حسب قراءتك وبحسب رؤيتك لهذا التطور ما
الملف الاسهل تفعيله اعلم بان الملفات
شائكه تعاون امني تعاون الامني هو في حد
ذاته يشمل العديد من الملفات الميليشيات
سياده الدول هناك ملفات اخرى اكثر تعقيد
ولكن من بينها كلها هل يمكن الحديث عن
اليمن
كبوابه او كعربون حسن ثقه هل تراه الاسهل
الابسط على الاقل ام لا
انا بتقديري الملف الاسهل
وربما مرشح للتفاوض الملف السوري
وبعده ياتي الملف اللبناني ولكن اعتقد ان
يعني حسب ما ارى في طهران وفي السياسه
هناك والتوجهات الحاكمه لا اعتقد ان الملف
اليمني هو سيكون ملف سهل نحن في هذه
الاتفاقيه نرى شيء جدا ملموس وواضح في
المفاوضات السابقه التي جرت في العراق
وقبله في سلطنه عمان اعتقد المملكه
العربيه كانت تركز اولا على حل الملف
الامني وترتيب الملف الامني مع ايران ثم
فتح
السفارات وفتح سبل الدبلوماسيه ولكن عندما
جاءت الضمان الصينيه الان الضمان الصينيه
هي مرتبطه بموضوع الملف الامني ولذلك
اعتقد ان الضمان الصينيه الان هي على
المحك موجوده على المحك في كل الملفات
وخاصه في الملف اليمني ولكن انا لا اعتقد
ان الملف اليمني سيكون ملف سهل انا اعتقد
ان النظام الايراني لديه هناك طموح برنامج
وتطلعات في هذا الملف خاصه المتشددين ولا
ارى ان هناك تراجعا في توجهات خيلك القدس
حول هذا الملف ولكن ايضا في المقابل هناك
موجودين وايضا سيركزون على ضمان الصينيه
وان هذه الضمانه في المعهد وان لا يمكن
للنظام الايراني في ظل هذه الظروف يعارض
هذه الضمان هو في الواقع لماذا سالت عن
الملف اليمني وسؤال حضرتك استاذ جاسم لان
الملف اليمني لا يتعلق فقط بالحرب لا
يتعلق فقط بذراع ايران في داخل اليمني
يتعلق كذلك بالاقتصاد العالمي يتعلق كذلك
بممرات التجاره العالميه وحضرتك تعلم بان
هذا موضوع حساس دوليا في ظل متغيرات
نعيشها بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه خنقت الجميع
فهذه نقطه كذلك مهمه لاقتصاد العالمي
تامين الملاحه البحريه قد تكون نقطه مهمه
فوددت سماع رؤيتك ورايك فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع ملف اليمن تتفق مع الدكتور
هاشميان بانه مؤجل ام ان كل هذه العناصر
قد تجعله موضوع على الطاوله
لا اتفق اطلاقا مع الدكتور حسن ملف اليمني
في في الدائره الاولى وليس في الدائره
وليس مؤجل لا اعتقد انه يعني العيبان
جلسوا في بكين اربعه ايام يشربان القهوه
ويتناول الكيك كان هناك من المؤكد انه
تفاصيل نقاط محدده ننقشه واحده واحده لم
يكن المساله ليست فقط
ليست المملكه بحاجه لعاد العلاقات يذكرنا
سنظل في نفس هذه الدائره وفي نفس هذه
الاشكالات المساله نتحدث عن المستقبل
ولذلك تحديد الشهرين مهمه تحديد الشهرين
اطار عمل ماذا سنلمس لماذا لم تقل يقول
بيان اعاده فتح العلاقات استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بينها وترك مفتوحه وعلى لقاء
لماذا حدد شهرين شهرين ترى مثلا مهمه يبدو
انا في ظني ان هناك التزامات ايرانيه
بخطوات معينه تتم خلال هذا الشهرين في
المجالين في الملف اليمني وفي التعاون
الامني النقطه الاخرى
تحديد اضافه الاتفاقيه التجاريه وال
والثقافيه وضعها يعني مؤشر على النظره
للمستقبل نعم انه يبدون هناك فعلا خطوات
تم الاجراء عليها باقي تنفيذها على
تنفيذها اليوم وانا اعتقد انها ستنفذ في
جوانب منها ولذلك الملف اليمني يجب نحسب
الملف اليمني ليش تهديدا فقط للسعوديه
تهديدا ملاح اليوم حتى ايران اذا كانت
تعتقد في وقت ماضي ان ان وجودها في اليمن
هو قوه لها لا اليوم هو ضعف لها اليوم هي
محاصره ونحن شاهدنا في الفتره الاخيره كيف
تحركت حتى الشركاء الاوروبيين والغربيين
في محاصره ومصادره الاسلحه التي كانت
ترسلها ايران يعني في الوقت اللي كنا
نتفاوض مع ايران في بغداد كانت ترسل
الاسلحه الحوثي لا احد ياخذ المساله بسرعه
عاطفيه المساله ليست عاطفيه هناك مشاكل
واضحه ومحدده ندركها جميعا ونعرف وهناك
خطوات نلمسها معلومات نحن نتكلم على
افتراضات وبالتالي ما يحدث اليمن يجب ان
يتغير
كليا
وباداه اجل بحسب رايك على كل تبقى
المواضيع عديده سنتحدث بام عان عن الصين
كوسيطه عن الملف النووي عن نقاط اخرى في
حلقات بانوراما لهذا الاسبوع سنخصصها كلها
لهذا التطور المهم او شكركم جزيل الشكر
على الحضور ومشاركتنا هذا نقاش من القاهره
بالفهم وزير الخارجيه السابق من رياض جسر
الجيش الكاتب الصحفي ومن واشنطن دكتور حسن
هاشم يلا اكاديمي والباحثه شان الايراني
شكرا لكم السلام عليكم